hallo leute vor kurzem waren wir mit
unseren ingenieuren team in
verschiedenen städten in deutschland
unterwegs und haben ein video über
regionale dialekte in deutschland
gemacht und zwar haben wir menschen auf
der straße gefragt ob sie einen
regionalen dialekt sprechen und ochsen
ihr frühstück in diesem dialekt
beschreiben können wir fangen an in
baden württemberg dort spricht man vor
allem alemannisch und schwäbisch rapid
morgen mit butter und marmelade
gefrühstückt ich habe heute morgen müßig
frühstückt mit was haferflocken ist er
sich ja verschiedene sonnenblumenkerne
verschiedene kerne so war es genau woher
kommst du ich komme aus bad waldsee aus
ober schauen was hast du heute morgen
gefrühstückt auf schwäbisch ein weg
presley cells ein brötchen mit
erdbeermarmelade ok kannst es schwer ich
möchte etwas versprechen soll das rezept
vor zählt also aber wenn jetzt haben wir
hier schlage erst mal fünf euro in
scheeßel dann naja je nach gusto sprudel
oder oder milch und dann halt nähe des
platzes schlecht sag ich mal
wow das ist echt schwierig zu verstehen
in deutschland gibt es ungefähr 20
verschiedene dialekt gruppen und in
einer umfrage des instituts für deutsche
sprache haben ungefähr 50 prozent aller
deutschen an dass sie neben dem
hochdeutschen auch einen regionalen
dialekt sprechen und diese regionalen
dialekte die sind ganz unterschiedlich
ausgeprägt auf dem land spricht man eher
dialekte als in der stadt und im süden
von deutschland spricht man mehr
dialekte als im norden besonders
ausgeprägt im süden ist der bayerische
dialekt
woher kommst du landkreis traunstein
beim chiemsee was hast du heute morgen
gefrühstückt
also habe porridge kissen mit geigen und
banane nur noch hoffen weil ich dazu
woher kommst du aus mainburg in
niederbayern ihre partei denn dafür
müsste mich als ihren schwarm gießen mit
seminar das war total gelungen aber
sommer hält kern dessen was hast du
heute morgen gefrühstückt als erhalten
dafür aber spiegelt essen und ja wenn es
nix in der früh weil ich ihn derweil
kosten muss weil meine freundin sagt
immer sie so dick bin im norden von
deutschland gibt es weniger dialekte als
im süden von deutschland
allerdings gibt es im norden auch einige
eigene sprachen so zum beispiel die
friesischen sprachen und das
plattdeutsche auf unserer tour haben wir
auch einen mann aus varel in
niedersachsen getroffen der ein wenig
plattdeutsch spricht was haben sie heute
morgen gefrühstückt hätte pott kaffee
hag brötchen basecap trug mord und
konfitüre schmeckt und dennoch ein glas
saft die tabletten mit ja auch irgendwie
drin und der wird als nächstes schauen
wir uns an wie menschen in leipzig ihr
frühstück beschreiben in leipzig spricht
man den sächsischen dialekt heute morgen
habe ich ein brötchen gegessen in der
schule und zwar mit frischkäse und ja es
hat gut geschmeckt kollecker eine b2b
habe ich gegessen das schnitten oder
sind das brot oder das sind ja schatten
brotscheiben eine bremer auf sächsisch
wir sagen auch manchmal wenn wir nicht
wissen was erstmal denn heute abend was
kommt man denn und kann er hat mir ideen
und so macht wie es mit brot endlich
haben deutschen brötchen gegessen mit
marmelade butter dämme und schlürfen
unseren klinischen kaffee ist was
sächsisches kennt kennt ihr das
der bremischen kaffee also kaffee im
café und wenn er besonders dünn ist und
die sachsen trinken glaube ich viel
dünger also ich selber trinkt zwar
starken kaffee aber in den in den
gaststätten gibt es eher dünnen kaffee
und den kontinenten klinischen kaffee
und zwar weil früher hatte man ja oft
blumenmuster im porzellan in der
porzellantasse und wenn der kaffee so
dünn war dass man unten dass man durch
den kaffee die blume durch sehen konnte
dann dann war es ein blümchen café
bremischen café zum abschluss schauen
wir uns noch zwei dialekte aus
westdeutschland an nämlich den
rheinischen dialekt und das trierer
platt erhöht neue zum frühstück hatte
die brötchen mit mitklatscht kies und
marmelade das heißt jetzt auf deutsch
mit quark und marmelade helmut kannst du
einmal im trierer platt beschreiben was
du heute morgen gefrühstückt hast klar
heute was gekocht
dann hatte ich den wunsch merkel hat da
ist es schwer gehabt haben wir noch
schön marmelade gemacht und dann
performance t mit bisschen höher nicht
drin gut rum geräte pfefferminz hand ich
daheim selbst geerntet als regional und
das war super frühstück ist dann ist sie
nicht 50 kilometer bis drastisch
gefallen mein frühstück
jetzt denkt ihr bestimmt so viele
dialekte in deutschland nein was soll
ich machen soll ich jetzt einen dialekt
lernen wenn ihr nach deutschland kommt
solltet ihr unbedingt hochdeutsch lernen
hochdeutsch wird eigentlich überall
verstanden wird auch in den meisten
städten in deutschland gesprochen und es
ist auch immer die basis dafür wenn ihr
tatsächlich einen dialekt lernen möchte
und wenn ihr jetzt hochdeutsch lernen
möchtet dann könnt ihr zum beispiel
unsere app sie lenkt benutzen weil ihnen
gibt es ganz verschiedene aufgaben und
unter anderem gibt es eine aufgabe in
der ihr selbst euer gesprochenes deutsch
aufnehmen
müsst und euch später nochmal anhören
könnt dadurch könnt ihr eure deutsche
aussprache schritt für schritt
verbessern
hier könnt ihr direkt zu wählen gehen
und hier unten gibt es noch weitere
links zu den deutschen dialekten tschüss
und bis sonntag
[Musik]